ron desantis by the way is it a war with
disney over the don't say gay bill
because he said disney's woke and
don't say gay bill by the way that i
have a funny bid on it now on stage but
from what i looked into it's just you
can't instruct the kids on gender theory
before they're three or something
kindergarten to second grade yeah who
disagrees with that really who needs
what are we doing and there already
wasn't a curriculum in place uh in that
state yes it was like don't bring in a
new curriculum to teach people to teach
seven-year-olds about gender they just
doesn't need to happen right
it doesn't need to happen nobody thinks
it needs to happen
um
but this really gets to the heart of the
uh problem where
uh there is this argument uh that i
would be very sympathetic to that a lot
of kids when they are young that
experience
uh some type of gender dysphoria if it's
not major gender dysphoria a lot of them
will end up just kind of being gay
perhaps they will not feel the need to
physically alter themselves some will
some are probably genuinely 100 trans
but if a six-year-old wears a dress they
could be experimenting they're having
fun maybe they end up being gay it may
not be
uh
something that is really indicative of
how they want to live the rest of their
life i think that's a pretty rational
sane position i don't think it's a crazy
turf insane position which again is you
know another word that we've made up to
just you know if you recognize any
biological difference between a man and
a woman you're a turf and again
the vast majority of people do recognize
those differences and that isn't at all
a rejection of trans identity or or
trying to hurt trans people now there
are some people that make it their
entire brand they speak about nothing
except the differences between men and
women which is you know it's maybe a
little suspect a little sass where it's
like the only thing you talk about over
and over again and they do it on both
sides well where are the trans people in
the ukraine gonna go and it's just every
single minute is trans trans transgender
are there de-transitioners in the
ukraine what about them what about the
people who cut their tents over the
ukraine and what that it's back and you
go why is this every day all day every
minute every minute
every second of the day we're doing this
over and over again because i guess it's
just this is some people's beat
and i understand and there's people that
have written uh really interesting stuff
about it
and i understand that and it it it does
seem to be more and more of the culture
it's more and more of an issue people
are fighting about it more and more and
it's i'm a very who cares person on this
because uh number one i don't have
children number two
if i had children um i would you know i
would not want them altering their
bodies until they were old enough really
to fully make that conscious choice and
i've said that before i don't think
that's a a a a trans
um
exclusionary point of view now are there
parents that would disagree with me and
go no my child
genuinely feels that going through
puberty would be abuse and they and and
and because they are super trans there
should be a council to just decide if
your kid's really trans like there
should be a like a council of people
that go like you are legit there are
some kids that are trained if there's
like a four-year-old with like a beard
and she's like yum bro what up i'm like
all right just let her not have the tits
but a lot of them you feel like they're
just experimenting you know i could have
been trans when i was young like i i was
i had like very like feminine uh
qualities you know a lot of people do i
still do most men i know have feminine
qualities now like and they have sex
with women so
this idea that reducing everything to
this very
simplistic understanding of everything i
just i just i get a little worried when
the pharmaceutical companies get in bed
with everybody and they go they need
these and that and the hormones and the
pills and some kids do some kids are
genuinely trans and there needs to be a
way to decide that like why doesn't jk
rowling instead of just again with the
man woman man woman
do a new harry potter book about a
council of people who decides which
wizards are trans or not when they're
children
you know that hat
where you go to gryffindor or slytherin
because the sorting hat knows you better
than you know you well this we need a
sorting hat for trans kids to find out
who's really in and who's out because
you can't get well you can't get the
tits back right
you can get implants can't you just get
it back anyway
can't you just explain to the kids if if
you don't want titties but you might get
the titties
later but then the problem is you take
all the hormones and you're like oh
but i think if the top stop taking them
it'll wear off too but i don't know
maybe these uh hormones and pills aren't
nearly as effective as i think they are
uh yeah you got you have to keep taking
them you have to it's it's a regiment i
don't want to speak for the truth but so
let's say you're you're you're a kid
and you you you transition kind of
but i guess that does [ __ ] up your body
if you don't go through natural puberty
for sure yeah probably because my yeah
that's right but my whole thing is this
like
i'm i'm almost a fan of the take a tit
leave a tit model you ever see the take
a book leave a book
it's our last episode but do you ever
see what i mean here take a book leave a
book where uh usually like crazy old
librarian witch women will put out a
bowl of books like outside of their
homes or
outside of some place of business or
something and there'll be a take a book
leave a book and the the idea there is
that you take a book and replenish it
with a book that maybe you finished to
promote reading in the community i'm
almost a fan of the take a tit leave a
tit where
could can we make it easier and cheaper
for people to just get tits whenever
they want or take tits away
because the problem is how expensive
this all is isn't that the issue here
isn't it expensive because
you can't just walk in there and get uh
the poon made into a peen it's a little
bit of dough mark norman had a great
joke he's like you call a lot of these
people brave caitlyn jenner is brave
she's just rich
it was mark norman joke it's a brilliant
joke where it was like
it's not
some people just don't have that ability
is my point
because insurance doesn't cover these
procedures often right for sure but my
thing is it gets messy when it's kids
because kids don't know what they're
doing
you know they don't know the kids don't
really know and they might regret it
some of them might regret it some of
them do regret it right there's all
these d transitioners
katie herzog's written 15 novels about d
transitioners and they've been
translated into many different languages
she wrote a war and peace style novel in
russian about the transitioners
it was war and peace but what if
everyone had de-transitioned they were
trans and they went back
um
so that's my whole thing on this i think
kids need to be kids i think adults need
to leave kids alone we have a weird
society now where adults are all over
children and telling them what to do and
who to be and how to believe
i think children need to figure out who
they are i think
kids are going to figure out if they're
gay if they're trans they need to figure
that out with their with their own i
don't think that we need to
impose
a value system
on children
uh
that are too young to completely
understand what decisions they're making
i've said it a million times i'm just
wondering if there's a happy medium i'll
take it to leave a tent
is there a happy meal what about instead
of the operation let them dress
what about realistic prosthetics here we
go
give them a [ __ ]
that's like a like a fake [ __ ] oh
right like mr potato header like yes
instead of doing anything medical give
them
jelly tits or a fake [ __ ] or something
no i'm dead serious it's funny because
you can laugh at it but instead of doing
something that's irreversible why don't
you give them like a more realistic
bot like a suit to wear
is that not a good idea like oh you
think you're a dude here's a fake [ __ ]
now in a few years you might want a real
[ __ ] or you might take this off
and go i don't want the fake [ __ ]
anymore
it's not a bad idea has anyone pitched
this probably but it's a happy medium
right
it
if your son wants to be a chick instead
of doing something irreversible
medically
do like a missed out fire every morning
where you make him into the woman he
wants to be
if you had a son it can't be i mean
listen unless you're really homophobic
and i'm i'm sure not every dad would be
thrilled about not every dad would be
thrilled about
making your son doing your son drag
every morning but it could be fun
you buy them little um
the leopard coat and uh you know you
don't want to make it buffoonish but
they shouldn't be without style
now
is that a happy medium now like and and
then dad might not like it as the dad's
putting the wig on and doing the makeup
and the mom might go
listen you think this is you don't like
this well the other option is something
irreversible medical that we can't
afford and the dad goes
i guess you're right
and he adjusts the wig and he puts the
lipstick i mean literally who cares
i'm one of the most progressive people
when it comes to gender because i don't
care men women hermaphrodite i i've had
friends that i consider hermaphrodites
even though they're not i have friends
where like i i know women with like
beards i've i've been friends with like
women with beards me and they honestly
used to talk about like italian women in
long island are all kind of trans
they're like
they're all very masculine like this
whole idea of this gender there's this
rigid thing i do find antiquated and
outdated
so i'm just wondering if there's a happy
medium or if there is not a happy medium
i don't
i don't really know